now that we have the opportunity granted
by President Biden
to help the Venezuelans who came before
July 31st
be able to apply for temporary
protective status and what follows that
literally with the same application
is the work authorization that coveted
work authorization that's their ticket
to the American dream
that's New York's Democratic governor
Kathy hokel rolling out the welcome mat
for Venezuelan migrants coming to this
city but at the same time sending out
mixed messages hokel also calling in an
additional 150 National Guard members to
help process those migrants as the
crisis pushes the Empire State to the
brink joining us now New York city
councilman Joe Borelli who represents
Staten Island I mean that scene outside
of the Roosevelt Hotel unbelievable I
mean for so many of us who pass by there
every single day you see the lines of
people it's babies women's it's men I
mean the pictures we're now seeing in
the New York Post inside the Roosevelt
Hotel what are we going to do what is
the city going to do I mean this is a
massive cost that is mounting daily
unfortunately this is the new normal I
mean this is the the result of over
almost 120 000 people coming here in the
last 18 months there is almost nowhere
to put them we have leased almost every
single hotel that was available we've
now opened 10 cities and multiple of our
Parks but to give you an idea about the
cost seventy five thousand dollars per
person per year means that this city is
basically starting the most expensive
social welfare program any city has ever
made in the history of this country and
it was done without any deliberation
without any legislative oversight
without any legislation it was done
because we decided to Virtue signal as a
sanctuary City and now New Yorkers are
left with the bill and the mayor is left
a bit dumbfounded you remember what he
said right weeks ago just for all this
and we'll listen to it yet again I don't
see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City we're getting 10
000 migrants a month and the buses just
keep rolling in that was weeks ago
President Biden was here last week for
four days those two guys never even
talked you know it's a shame because
this is the Biden disaster remember uh
2020 2021 he was running on changing the
Trump policy he came in in January 21 he
changed the border and Customs tactics
he ended MPP remain in Mexico he
appointed Kamala Harris as the borders
are to get to the root cause and the net
result 18 months almost two years later
is that a hundred thousand people have
come to this city and have now uh
basically fleeced the American taxpayers
fleece New Yorkers we are spending more
than the entire budget of Mississippi in
the next fiscal year on this crisis your
ear to the ground you're talking to
residents of this city every single day
what are people saying I think the
pendulum finally uh flipped back I think
people are finally getting sick of this
we're starting to see protests and not
just sort of the conservative
neighborhoods we're seeing protests in
every neighborhood now where my shelters
are opening up you know homeless
shelters used to be controversial things
for any City we used to deliberate them
and argue about them now to have 206
open up willy-nilly overnight in the
course of one year has put too much
pressure on New Yorkers who are sick of
their quality of life just being
affected by this problem the president
has chosen not to talk about this or
even explain this position maybe perhaps
he could argue but on a lot of things
but not just the Border but Elon Musk is
going down there later in the week we're
told by Bill malusion a bit earlier
today and Robert Kennedy found a video
online he was at the border saying that
you know if you give a chance to elect
him you know he's challenging by I don't
know how far he's going to get on that
if you get a chance to
to elect him he would shut down the
border so maybe you're right Joe because
I I'm dubious that the tide is turning
but you think there's evidence to
suggest that it is oh I think it is I
think he saw Eric Adams come out and say
that the truth finally to the New York
public to the American public that this
is really costing too much money you saw
Kathy hope will come out and say let's
ask him for help they're not saying
close the border no they're not and
that's really the problem is that when
they get these temporary work
authorizations for this population of
Venezuelans that might if you think so
might solve the problem for the people
here but unless you close the border
every single one of these shelter beds
that that was you know saw a migrant
maybe get out because they're working
now it's going to be replaced by another
one or two coming across the border next
week uh Joe thank you for your time
um it's good to check in on you thanks
guys we'll stay in touch thank you okay
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights